hallo mein name ist ich sollte das
wirklich mit diesem blöden john cena
wird echt mal lassen wer wer hat ihn
eigentlich eingeführt war das nicht wir
spielen heute wegfall des happy das ist
eine gute dings auf jeden ich habe schon
mal so weg junger spieler gemacht vor
zigtausenden millionen von jahrzehnten
ich werde euch 14 da seht ihr dann lage
das ist brutal also wenn ihr keine lust
auf blut und körperteile und so hab dann
bitte und auch wenn ihr unter 18 seid
dann jagt weiter wenn ihr cool seid
einfach wir haben wir verschiedene
möglichkeiten und items that used by die
echse patient die macher sind auf jeden
fall klug ich klicke jetzt einfach mal
hier auf die kreditkarte drauf und kaufe
ihr autos und so läuft übrigens sicher
jede beziehung abgibt einer frau ihre
kreditkarte gekauft ein den ganzen da
kommt zurück
übrigens camp auf because of weil meine
haare gerade echt total absacker sind
ich wähle jetzt einfach mal den laptop
und war auch nur ganz gute taktik ist
das hier unten ein
[Applaus]
er muss sich jetzt erst mal stockt regen
gehofft diese brutalität hier
hier ist ja ein ganz normales geschenkt
und das kann doch eigentlich nicht
logisch sein das muss wir probieren wir
mal das herz geschenkt aussieht das ist
ganz normal ist hier das ist schön für
sie freut sich die macht des ausschusses
ist braucht das letzte geschenk was wir
noch haben ist von hier an ihn und es
sind boxern hier und jetzt
wie was ist denn das braune gold freunde
wir haben hier eine neue freundin von
ihnen glaube ich aber das machen wir
einfach als setzt denn hier liegt noch
ein schwert glaubt so ich glaube ich
muss wirklich wieder eine warnung an den
titel schreiben so sperrt youtube das
video ich bin halt über 18 deswegen kann
ich mir halt die ganze videos über 18
sind anschauen und ich denke dass viele
von euch auch einfach ein falsches alter
bei youtube angegeben haben so dass die
videos über 18 anschauen können
allerdings ist das jetzt mal eine frage
an alle die ihr richtiges alter
angegeben haben und vielleicht irgendwie
15 16 sind oder so um den dreh könnt ihr
gerade dieses videos sehen
ja wenn ich es nicht sehen könnt könnt
ihr ja dass auch gerade nicht hören was
sich hier gerade sage also wenn ihr bei
youtube irgendwie jünger als 18
eingegeben seid dann schreibt immer mit
dem kommentare wie das video sehen
können weil das ist doch einfach viel zu
brutal ich nehme jetzt mal einfach den
schuh und das ist doch mal eine frau
freut sich doch über schuhe und dann
dann gehen wir doch einfach mal hier ja
war super toll was hat das jetzt mit dem
schuh zu tun
ach so ich habe sie mit dem schuljahr
getreten ich bis jetzt ein
ein schöner sessel mit bier kummer und
dann auch direkt war ich gerade schon an
blumen hey guckt euch das an da bin ich
da hab ich schon keinen kopf mehr
was ist denn das sie für eine kacke und
sie nimmt einen raketenwerfer und macht
natürlich dem fernseher kaputt und ich
bin natürlich so klug und glaubt jetzt
weg und sie machten mich auch noch
kaputt und da geht doch schon der form
zu und ziehen
natürlich macht sich einsetzt laut
aufgebot das hier ist ein gerät mit
einem schalter dran rund 100 leichen aus
wie kacke ich klicke jetzt einfach mal
er nimmt mich wirklich nur aus seinem
arsch und schießt ihn ein
ok ich nehme jetzt noch einmal den
partyhit hier unten ich glaube nämlich
den hatten wir
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt nehmen wir das noch dass wir alle
gewartet haben die option auf den wir
alle gewartet haben das gewisse etwas an
diesem video das wir alle gewartet haben
wir nehmen die lesbisch
[Musik]
ja meine damen und herren damit würde
ich sah und kinder und frauen und
haustiere damit beende ich jetzt dieses
video wenn es euch gefallen habe würde
ich mich über eine bewertung freund
wollt ihr mehr von solchen comic
gemäßigten sachen so was wie die
stickerin reihe oder irgendwas dann
schreibt mir vorschläge und in die
kommentare dann werde ich davon mehr
machen ich sage immer dass euch das
super gefällt wenn ich so point and
click sachen mache so ein browser